Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Ever since she was a little girl, Maria Chincway had always dreamed of starting a family of her own. Her wish was fulfilled on June 11, 1971, when she gave birth to her first child, a boy named Giuseppe. He inherited his name from his grandfather but was known to friends and family as Joe. Maria and her husband Nino,
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目说明。从小时候起，玛丽亚·钦克韦就一直梦想着组建自己的家庭。1971年6月11日，她的愿望实现了，她生下了第一个孩子，一个名叫朱 Giuseppe 的男孩。他继承了他祖父的名字，但朋友和家人都叫他乔。玛丽亚和她的丈夫尼诺，
who were both Italian immigrants, were besotted with Joe, describing him as the most beautiful baby they had ever seen. Four years later, Maria gave birth to their second child, a boy named Anthony. The family of four lived in a neat two-story red brick house in Newcastle, a harbour city on Australia's east coast, 160km north from Sydney. Maria and Nino relished the constant buzz of activity their sons contributed around their household and looked forward to each evening when the family would gather for dinner at the kitchen table and share stories about their day. The walls of the Chincway's home were adorned with
他们两人都是意大利移民，对乔疼爱有加，称他为他们见过的最漂亮的婴儿。四年后，玛丽亚生下了他们的第二个孩子，一个名叫安东尼的男孩。这四口之家住在澳大利亚东海岸港口城市纽卡斯尔一栋整洁的两层红砖房里，这里距离悉尼以北160公里。玛丽亚和尼诺很享受他们的儿子们为家庭带来的源源不断的活力，并期待着每天傍晚全家人围坐在厨房桌旁吃晚餐，分享他们一天的故事。钦克韦家的墙壁上挂满了
family photos and trophies. Joe was a natural athlete and spent his school years playing every sport he could, including tennis, cricket and soccer. He was popular amongst his classmates, well-liked by his teachers and maintained good grades. He intended to study architecture at university but by the time he graduated from high school he decided he didn't want a career that would keep him inside all day and switched to civil engineering instead. In November 1994, at the age of 24, Joe completed his engineering degree and celebrated the milestone by travelling through Europe for two months. Upon his return to Australia he resumed living at home with his parents. He started work as a project manager for the same civil engineering company
家庭照片和奖杯。乔是个天生的运动员，学生时代参加了他能参加的所有运动，包括网球、板球和足球。他在同学中很受欢迎，深受老师喜爱，并且成绩保持得很好。他原本打算在大学攻读建筑学，但在高中毕业时，他觉得自己不想从事整天待在室内的职业，于是转而学习土木工程。1994年11月，24岁的乔完成了工程学位，并以在欧洲旅行两个月的行程来庆祝这一里程碑。回到澳大利亚后，他恢复了与父母同住的生活。他开始在一家土木工程公司担任项目经理，该公司正是他的父亲和祖父曾工作过的地方，
where his father and grandfather were employed, earning a reputation as a hard-working and dependable person. In his spare time he played sports, went to the gym and socialised, with people naturally drawn to his easy-going attitude and sense of humour. At the beginning of 1995, Joe joined his mates for a night out at a club in town called The Brewery. There he met 22-year-old Anu Singh. She had just completed a Bachelor of Economics at the Australian National University in Canberra and had returned to Newcastle to spend the summer with her family. Anu was born in the Punjab region of India but had relocated to Australia with her parents when she was two years old. Both her mother and father were medical practitioners and Anu was the eldest
并赢得了勤奋可靠的好名声。闲暇时，他做运动、去健身房、进行社交活动，他随和的态度和幽默感自然而然地吸引了周围的人。1995年年初，乔和同伴们一起去城里的一家名为“啤酒厂”的俱乐部过夜。在那里，他遇到了22岁的阿努·辛格。她刚刚在堪培拉的澳大利亚国立大学获得经济学学士学位，并回到纽卡斯尔与家人共度夏天。阿努出生于印度的旁遮普地区，两岁时随父母移居澳大利亚。她的母亲和父亲都是开业医师，阿努是他们两个孩子中的老大。
of their two children. She was well-spoken, intelligent and excelled academically but was also known to behave questionably at times. Although she had a long-term boyfriend, Anu hit it off with Joe and the pair commenced a romantic fling. When she returned to Canberra, her boyfriend Simon found out about her infidelity and ended their relationship. Following the breakup, Anu began seeing Joe again on a casual basis. In mid-1996, they entered a long-distance relationship while Anu returned to study law at Canberra's Australian National University, 450km south of Newcastle. The couple initially kept their relationship a secret from Anu's parents, who wanted her to
她谈吐文雅，聪明伶俐，学业优异，但也时常做出一些令人匪夷所思的行为。尽管她有一个交往已久的男友，但阿努和乔一见如故，两人开始了一段浪漫的恋情。当她回到堪培拉时，她的男友西蒙发现了她的不忠并结束了他们的关系。分手后，阿努开始与乔保持随意的交往。1996年年中，随着阿努返回堪培拉的澳大利亚国立大学（位于纽卡斯尔以南450公里处）继续攻读法律，他们开始了一段异地恋。这对情侣最初对阿努的父母隐瞒了他们的恋情，因为她的父母希望她在
remain single while she completed her studies. Joe told his family that if the Sings ever called their house wanting to know who he was, they should say he was a friend of Anu's brother. He was completely smitten with Anu and prioritised her above all else, racking up expensive phone bills by calling her up to 15 times a day. Every Friday afternoon, he made the five and a half hour drive to see her, returning home in the early hours of Monday morning to begin work at 9am. Anu had several long-going health problems, and if she was unwell, Joe would sometimes leap work in the middle of the week and fly to Canberra to take care of her.
完成学业期间保持单身。乔告诉他的家人，如果辛格夫妇打电话到家里来打听他是谁，他们就说他是阿努哥哥的朋友。他对阿努倾注了全部心血，把她看得高于一切，最高纪录是一天给她打15个电话，积攒了昂贵的电话费。每周五下午，他都要开五个半小时的车去看她，然后在周一凌晨赶回家，开始早上9点的工作。阿努长期患有多种健康问题，如果她身体不适，乔有时会在周中翘班，飞往堪培拉照顾她。
Maria and Nino Chinque noticed a distinct change in their son's behaviour after he started dating Anu. According to the book Joe Chinque's Consolation by Helen Garner, Maria warned Joe not to let Anu control him, to which he replied, Don't make me choose, I love you, but she needs me. In September 1996, Joe permanently relocated to Canberra to live with Anu. The couple moved into a semi-detached brick townhouse on the busy tree-lined thoroughfare Revental Street in the suburb of Downer, four kilometres from Anu's university. They had grand plans for their future and opened a joint bank account called
玛丽亚和尼诺·钦克韦注意到，自从儿子开始与阿努交往后，他的行为发生了明显的变化。根据海伦·加纳所著的书《乔·钦克韦的慰藉》，玛丽亚曾警告乔不要让阿努控制他，乔对此回答说：“别逼我做选择，我爱你们，但她需要我。”1996年9月，乔永久搬到堪培拉与阿努同居。这对情侣搬进了一栋半独立式砖砌联排别墅，位于唐尔郊区繁华、绿树成荫的雷文塔尔街，距离阿努的大学有四公里。他们对未来有着宏伟的计划，并开立了一个名为
Anu and Joe's Marriage Account. In November, Anu finished her studies for the year, and the couple spent three weeks in Newcastle staying with the Joe's parents. Maria Chinque described Anu as the perfect house guest, but deep down, she had an instinctive feeling that Anu was not right for her son. Before Anu entered a relationship with Joe, she had been left devastated by her breakup with Simon. She was particularly hurt by a claim he made that she was, quote, intellectually inferior. The comment had a profound impact on the headstrong Anu, who had a tendency to look down on those she deemed stupid, and it marked a dramatic turning
“阿努和乔的婚姻账户”的联名银行账户。11月，阿努完成了当年的学业，这对情侣在乔的父母家纽卡斯尔住了三个星期。玛丽亚·钦克韦将阿努形容为完美的做客客人，但内心深处，她有一种直觉，觉得阿努并不适合她的儿子。在阿努与乔交往之前，她曾因与西蒙的分手而悲痛欲绝。她尤其被西蒙声称她“智力低下”的言论所伤。这句话对性格固执、有时会看不起那些她认为愚蠢的人的阿努产生了深远的影响，这也标志着她行为的一个戏剧性转折点。
point in her behaviour. She started experimenting with amphetamines and obsessed over her physical appearance, spending hours at the gym to maintain her figure. By late 1995, Anu had developed bulimia, a needing disorder characterised by binge eating episodes followed by self-induced vomiting, fasting, and the misuse of laxatives and diuretics. She spiralled into a deep depression and moved back in with her parents, who were deeply concerned by her behaviour. She only consumed soft drinks and the occasional chocolate biscuit, and begged her father to pay for her to get liposuction. He encouraged her to seek professional help, but she refused to admit that she was suffering. Joe was aware of the struggles Anu
她开始尝试使用苯丙胺，并痴迷于自己的外表，花数小时在健身房维持身材。到1995年底，阿努已经患上了贪食症，这是一种以暴食发作随后采取自我催吐、禁食以及滥用泻药和利尿剂为特征的进食障碍。她陷入了深深的抑郁，并搬回了与父母同住，她的父母对她的行为深感担忧。她只喝软饮料和偶尔吃一块巧克力饼干，并恳求父亲出钱让她做抽脂手术。父亲鼓励她寻求专业帮助，但她拒绝承认自己正在遭受痛苦。乔知道阿努正在面对的挣扎，并全心全意地支持她，因为照顾人的角色对他来说是自然而然的。
was facing and supported her wholeheartedly as a caretaking role came naturally to him. When he was eight years old, his family was involved in a serious car accident. Maria suffered a debilitating foot injury, and young Joe stepped up to help with the household chores. Despite being told it was a doctor's responsibility to help Anu, Joe continued to take care of her, calling her more than a dozen times per day, visiting her whenever she requested, and eventually moving to Canberra to live with her. With Joe by her side, Anu's condition showed no signs of improvement. By 1997, she became completely fixated on her health and complained about a range of physical symptoms,
在他八岁时，他的家人遭遇了一场严重的车祸。玛丽亚遭受了使她残疾的足部受伤，年幼的乔挺身而出帮助做家务。尽管有人告诉他帮助阿努是医生的责任，但乔仍然继续照顾她，每天给她打十几个电话，在她每次要求时去看望她，并最终搬到堪培拉和她一起生活。在乔的陪伴下，阿努的病情没有丝毫改善。到1997年，她完全沉迷于自己的健康，并抱怨一系列身体症状，
including aching legs, hot flushes, and chronic fatigue. She withdrew from social events and rarely attended her university lectures. When she did, classmates noted she looked uncharacteristically dishevelled. She told a friend there was something wrong with her metabolism and her muscles were being eaten away. But doctors couldn't find anything wrong and diagnosed her issues as purely psychological. Anu maintained there was nothing wrong with her mind and it was only her body that had problems. At one stage, her mother found her frantically pacing her room in tears, saying things were crawling under her skin and it felt like her head was attached to someone
包括腿部酸痛、潮热和慢性疲劳。她退出了社交活动，很少去大学上课。当她去上课时，同学们注意到她看起来一反常态地衣衫褴褛。她告诉一位朋友，她的新陈代谢出了问题，肌肉正在被侵蚀。但医生们找不到任何问题，并将她的问题诊断为纯粹的心理问题。阿努坚称她的精神没有任何问题，出问题的只有她的身体。有一次，她母亲发现她在房间里焦躁不安地踱步，泪流满面，说着有什么东西在皮肤下爬行，感觉她的头像是连在别人的身体上一样。
else's body. Following this incident, Anu agreed to see a psychiatrist, who referred her to another doctor, but she never followed through with the appointment. In March 1997, Anu approached Maria Chinque, hoping she would understand her ongoing health issues given Maria's own experience following the car accident. Anu was anxiously pacing and fidgeting, bleeding Maria to wonder whether she was going through drug withdrawals. Months later, Anu was convinced she had contracted AIDS. She told a friend it was unfair that Joe was unaffected by the disease and that she planned to put her infected blood on his toothbrush. When the results of her AIDS test came back negative, Anu considered the possibility that
这起事件发生后，阿努同意去看精神科医生，医生将她转诊给另一位医生，但她从未去复诊。1997年3月，阿努找到玛丽亚·钦克韦，希望她能鉴于玛丽亚车祸后的自身经历，理解她持续的健康问题。阿努焦虑地踱步、坐立不安，这让玛丽亚怀疑她是否正在经历戒毒反应。几个月后，阿努确诊自己感染了艾滋病。她告诉一位朋友，乔没有感染这种疾病是不公平的，她计划将自己感染的血液涂在乔的牙刷上。当她的艾滋病检测结果呈阴性时，阿努开始考虑
she had a crippling nervous system condition like multiple sclerosis or peripheral neuropathy. She showered up to seven times a day and told her father that she thought she was going to die. Her mother contacted a mental health crisis team and tried to have Anu admitted for treatment, but as she wasn't considered a danger to herself or others, they couldn't admit her without her permission. Anu blamed her undiagnosed condition on Ithaca cira, a vomit inducing medication. Joe had once mentioned it during a conversation about how supermodels were able to control their appetites. Although he refused to talk to her about it any further, she resented him for inadvertently introducing her to the medication, which she used to maintain her weight.
自己患有像多发性硬化症或周围神经病变这样致残性神经系统疾病的可能性。她一天洗高达七次澡，并告诉父亲她觉得自己快要死了。她的母亲联系了心理健康危机小组，试图让阿努入院治疗，但由于她不被认为对她自己或他人构成危险，他们在没有她允许的情况下无法让她入院。阿努将她未确诊的病情归咎于吐根糖浆，这是一种催吐药物。乔曾在一次关于超级名模如何控制食欲的对话中提到过它。尽管他拒绝再跟她谈论此事，但她怨恨他无意中向她介绍了这种药物，她用它来维持体重。
In late May, Anu told a friend she hated Joe and wanted to go on a rampage to kill him, her ex-boyfriend Simon, and all the incompetent doctors she had seen. She added, quote, I studied psychiatric text and it wouldn't be too hard to convince someone you're insane. The next month, she visited Canberra's National Library with her closest friend, fellow law student Mardavi Rao. Like Anu, Mardavi had high-achieving Indian parents and excelled academically but was the quieter, more studious of the pair. They sourced a book written by the Hemlock Society, an American organization that advocated an individual's right to die. It contained information on assisted suicide and relevant legislation surrounding the issue, and the pair
5月下旬，阿努告诉一位朋友，她恨乔，想大开杀戒，杀了他、她的前男友西蒙以及她看过的所有无能的医生。她补充说：“我研究过精神病学教科书，要让人相信你疯了并不难。”第二个月，她和最亲密的朋友、同为法学院学生的马尔达维·拉奥一起参观了堪培拉的国家图书馆。和阿努一样，马尔达维也有着成就斐然的印度父母，学业优异，但她是两人中更安静、更刻苦的一个。她们找到了一本由美国倡导个人安乐死权利的组织——铁杉协会撰写书。其中包含有关协助自杀的信息以及围绕该问题的相关立法，两人
photocopied various pages. A month later, Anu asked a friend if he could help her obtain a gun, telling him she was suffering from permanent neurological damage and wanted to end her life. A week later, the same friend spotted Anu sitting in her car in the city and she told him she was trying to buy a gun. Thinking she was joking, he playfully warned her she was going to get ripped off. Shortly after, Anu told another classmate that she was sick and wanted to die. She had been studying methods of suicide and decided a gunshot wound was preferable and asked for help to buy a firearm. Her classmate thought their conversation was, quote, too silly for words and didn't think she was being serious, even when she phoned him days
复印了各种页面。一个月后，阿努问一个朋友是否能帮她弄一把枪，告诉他她正在遭受永久性神经损伤，想要结束自己的生命。一周后，同一个朋友在城里看到阿努坐在车里，她告诉他她正在试图买枪。以为她在开玩笑，他开玩笑地警告她她会被敲竹杠。不久之后，阿努告诉另一个同学她生病了想死。她一直在研究自杀方法，并决定枪伤更可取，并请求帮助购买枪支。她的同学认为他们的对话“荒谬得无法用言语形容”，根本不相信她是认真的，甚至在几天后她打电话
later asking if he had any luck getting one. That same month, Anu told another acquaintance about her plans to use a gun to end her life. They advised that an intentional heroin overdose would be a much better way to die. Anu organized to sell a large collection of her clothes at $1 or $2 per item, telling her father she no longer needed them as she never went out. She also started giving away her CDs, claiming she no longer listened to them. Her parents reached out to the mental health crisis team again, this time submitting an application to have a new hospitalised against her will. But before any action could be taken, the application had to be approved by a magistrate, and it was scheduled for review in due course.
询问是否有运气弄到一把枪时也是如此。同一个月，阿努向另一位熟人讲述了她打算用枪结束自己生命的计划。他们建议蓄意过量注射海洛因会是更好的死法。阿努组织以每件1美元或2美元的价格出售她的大量衣物，告诉父亲她不再需要它们了，因为她从来不出门。她还开始送出她的CD，声称她不再听了。她的父母再次联系了心理健康危机小组，这次提交了一份申请，要求将阿努非自愿住院。但在采取任何行动之前，该申请必须得到治安法官的批准，并且已按计划排期进行审查。
In late August of 1997, Anu inquired with a known drug user on campus about the logistics of overdosing on heroin. He explained that in excess quantities, heroin causes a user to stop breathing and die a painless death within minutes. He believed $150 worth of the illicit substance would be enough to cause a recreational user to overdose. A week later, Anu called him wanting to buy half a gram of heroin. She arrived at his house with her friend Mardavis, soon after, and exchanged $250 for the drug. The two women were shown how to prepare a hit, and were both injected for the first time. A month later, they attempted to shoot up on their own, but couldn't find the right veins, so they invited another of their friends over
1997年8月下旬，阿努向校园里的一名知名吸毒者询问了过量注射海洛因的后勤事宜。他解释说，过量的海洛因会导致吸毒者在几分钟内停止呼吸并无痛死亡。他认为价值150美元的违禁物质就足以让一个娱乐性吸毒者过量。一周后，阿努打电话给他，想要买半克海洛因。不久后，她和她的朋友马尔达维一起到达他家，用250美元交换了这种毒品。这两名女性被演示了如何准备一针，并且两人都是第一次被注射。一个月后，她们试图自己注射，但找不到合适的静脉，于是她们邀请了她们的另一个朋友过来
to redemonstrate the injection process. On Tuesday, September 23, Anu made an appointment with a university counsellor to discuss her relationship with Jo Qingwei. She divulged that the two were verbally and physically abusive to one another, and she wanted to end the relationship, but couldn't, as her medical condition meant she was financially and emotionally dependent on him. Weeks later, Anu purchased another gram of heroin. The dealer questioned why she needed so much, to which Anu responded, someone's coming with me. When asked if she intended to end her own life, Anu said yes, but refused to reveal who the other participant in her suicide pact was.
重新演示注射过程。9月23日星期二，阿努与学校辅导员预约，讨论她与乔·钦克韦的关系。她透露，两人在言语和肢体上互相虐待，她想结束这段关系，但又做不到，因为她的病情意味着她在经济和情感上都依赖他。几周后，阿努又买了一克海洛因。毒贩质问她为什么需要这么多，阿努回答说：“有人和我一起去。”当被问及她是否打算结束自己的生命时，阿努说是的，但拒绝透露她自杀协议中的另一个参与者是谁。
On Sunday, October 19, Jo visited his parents in Newcastle and told them he and Anu were hosting a dinner party the following evening. He asked if his mother had any meals prepared that he could serve his guests. Maria offered to cook something up, but Jo told her not to worry about it, and decided to pick up some fried chicken instead. The dinner party went ahead on Monday, October 20. Mardavi was invited and brought along another friend, Olivia, who had never met Jo or Anu before. Prior to the dinner, Mardavi showed Olivia a needle mark in her arm, explaining that Anu had been injecting her with heroin to practice for her own suicide. She revealed that the dinner was a final send-off, as Anu was planning to end her and Jo's
10月19日星期日，乔去纽卡斯尔看望他的父母，并告诉他们他和阿努将在第二天晚上举办晚宴。他问他母亲是否有准备好的饭菜可以招待客人。玛丽亚主动提出做点什么，但乔让她不用担心，决定去买一些炸鸡。晚宴于10月20日星期一如期举行。马尔达维受邀参加，并带了另一个朋友奥利维亚，奥利维亚以前从未见过乔或阿努。在晚宴之前，马尔达维向奥利维亚展示了她手臂上的一个针孔，解释说阿努一直在给她注射海洛因，以便为她自己的自杀进行练习。她透露说，这次晚宴是一场最后的欢送会，因为阿努计划在那天晚上结束她和乔的
lives that night. When the two women arrived at the Antle Street townhouse, Anu told them she had prepared way more food than was necessary for their small group of guests. The suburb they lived in was home to many other university students, so she told Mardavi and Olivia to door-knock the area to see if anyone else wanted to join them. By then, rumors of Anu's intentions had spread, spurring other students, some of whom were total strangers, to attend to the party out of morbid curiosity. Anu acted loving and happy towards her boyfriend and didn't appear suicidal, leading the group to suspect her plan had never been serious. The party ended without incident. Mardavi drove several of the guests home,
生命。当这两名女性到达安特尔街的联排别墅时，阿努告诉她们，她为他们这群少数客人准备的食物远远超出了需要。她们居住的郊区住了许多其他大学生，所以她告诉马尔达维和奥利维亚去该地区挨家挨户敲门，看看是否还有其他人想加入她们。到那时，关于阿努意图的谣言已经传开，促使其他学生，其中一些人甚至是完全的陌生人，出于病态的好奇心参加了派对。阿努对她的男友表现得深情而快乐，看起来并不想自杀，这导致大家怀疑她的计划从来都不是认真的。派对在没有发生意外的情况下结束了。马尔达维开车送几位客人回家，
telling them the suicide plot was going ahead later that night. Her passengers asked if they should seek medical help, but Mardavi ordered them not to do a thing. They were still uncertain if the entire scenario was a joke, but ultimately decided that it was Anu's choice if she wanted to end her own life and doctored not to get involved. Meanwhile, Anu had crushed some sedatives and sprinkled them into Joe's drink, causing him to drift off to sleep. She then fetched a pre-prepared syringe full of heroin and tried to inject it into him, but he was restless and she struggled to find the right vein. The liquid congealed, rendering it useless. Joe woke up the following
告诉他们自杀阴谋将在当晚晚些时候进行。她的乘客问他们是否应该寻求医疗帮助，但马尔达维命令他们什么也不要做。他们仍然不确定整个场景是否是个玩笑，但最终认为如果阿努想结束自己的生命那是她的选择，并决定不予干涉。与此同时，阿努压碎了一些镇静剂并把它们撒入乔的饮料中，导致他昏昏欲睡。然后她取出一支预先准备好的装满海洛因的注射器并试图将它注射到他体内，但他焦躁不安，她很难找到合适的静脉。液体凝固了，使其无法使用。乔在第二天醒来
morning and went to work, seemingly unaware of what Anu had attempted the night before. Anu contacted Mardavi and told her what she had done. The day after the dinner party, Mardavi went to the Community and Health Services Complaints Commission where she was undertaking work experience for her law degree. She told two colleagues that something really serious had happened the night before and was paranoid the police were after her. When they asked what had happened, Mardavi told them it was, quote, the major crime of the century. It's got to do with revenge. It's the worst thing in the Crimes Act. After her first attempt to kill Joe had failed, Anu asked one of her heroin user friends to
早晨去上班，似乎不知道阿努前一天晚上试图做什么。阿努联系了马尔达维，把她做的事告诉了她。晚宴后的第二天，马尔达维去了社区和健康服务投诉委员会，她在那里为自己的法学学位进行实习。她告诉两个同事前一天晚上发生了非常严重的事情，并且患有妄想症，觉得警察在追捕她。当他们问发生了什么事时，马尔达维告诉他们这是“世纪大案，这跟复仇有关。这是《犯罪法》中最糟糕的事情。”在第一次杀死乔的尝试失败后，阿努要求她的一位海洛因吸毒者朋友
source rehypno, a tranquilizing drug almost 10 times more potent than Valium. The sedative was often prescribed to help overcome heroin addiction and the friend had no problem obtaining a prescription from her general practitioner. Anu obtained 15 rehypno tablets and was told that when paired with heroin, only one tablet was needed to render a person unconscious. Anu Under notes to Joe, Anu scheduled a second dinner party for the following Friday night of October 24, once again telling guests that she intended to take her and to Joe's lives afterwards. When the evening arrived, Joe returned home from work to discover his house was filled with people.
寻找瑞海普诺，这是一种药效几乎是安定10倍的镇静剂。这种镇静剂通常被处方用来帮助克服海洛因成瘾，这位朋友从她的全科医生那里获得处方没有任何问题。阿努获得了15片瑞海普诺药片，并被告知当与海洛因配合使用时，只需要一片药片就能让人失去知觉。在乔不知情的情况下，阿努安排了10月24日星期五晚上的第二场晚宴，再次告诉客人她打算在事后结束她和乔的生命。当夜晚降临，乔下班回家，发现家里挤满了人。
Although he seemed surprised, he was a gracious and sociable host, welcoming guests and speaking excitedly about his new car and upcoming plans to holiday in Queensland. There were mixed reactions among the guests. Mardavi had told her friend Olivia that the suicide plot was going ahead for real this time, but Olivia dismissed her by saying, People who are going to do this sort of thing don't just talk about it, they go ahead and do it. But Mardavi was certain, telling colleagues and classmates beforehand that there was nothing she could do to stop it. Another guest thought the story was so absurd that it couldn't possibly be true, while others wrote it off as another of Anu's dramatic attention-seeking stories.
尽管他看起来很惊讶，但他是一位亲切合群的主人，热情地迎接客人，并兴奋地谈论他的新车和即将到来的昆士兰度假计划。客人们的反应不一。马尔达维曾告诉她的朋友奥利维亚，这次自杀阴谋这次是来真的了，但奥利维亚不屑一顾地对她说：“要干这种事的人才不会只挂在嘴边说说，他们直接就去做了。”但马尔达维很确定，事先告诉同事和同学她无力阻止。另一位客认为这个故事太荒谬了，不可能是真的，而另一些人则认为这只是阿努又一个博取眼球的戏剧性故事。
They showed up regardless, curious to see what would unfold. Joe was happy and affectionate towards Anu, who was noticeably vivacious and bubbly. When a friend inquired about her good mood, Anu said she had consumed a few drinks and taken some rehypnoll. The party continued without incident into the early hours. The group discussed plans to visit a casino, but the idea didn't go ahead, and people started heading home. Eventually, everyone left, except Mardavi. At six the following morning, Mardavi arrived home and told a friend who had spent the night there that Anu had put 10 rehypnoll tablets into Joe's coffee and tried to inject him with a
不管怎样，他们还是出现了，好奇地上前看看事情会如何发展。乔对阿努既高兴又深情，而阿努则明显显得生机勃勃、兴高采烈。当一位朋友询问她为什么心情这么好时，阿努说她喝了几杯饮料，并吃了一些瑞海普诺。派对在没有意外的情况下持续到凌晨。大家讨论了去赌场游玩的计划，但这个想法没有付诸实施，人们开始往家走。最后，除了马尔达维，所有人都离开了。第二天清晨六点，马尔达维回到家，告诉一个在那儿过夜的朋友，阿努把10片瑞海普诺药片放进乔的咖啡里，并试图给他注射
lethal dose of heroin. She explained, quote, It didn't work. It's amazing. It wasn't his time to go. When asked why Anu was trying to hurt Joe, Mardavi stated, Joe's the problem. She wants to take Joe with her. It's because she blames him for her condition. After consulting with her friend, Mardavi decided she wasn't going to have any further involvement in Anu's plan. As the day continued, word of Anu's persistent efforts to kill Joe spread throughout their friendship circle. One friend threatened to contact the police, but Anu found out and talked her out of it, reassuring she would never do anything to hurt Joe, saying, We're engaged to be married. You could ruin this for all of us.
致死剂量的海洛因。她解释说：“这没用。这太神奇了。现在还不是他走的时候。”当被问及为什么阿努要伤害乔时，马尔达维说：“乔是个问题。她想带乔一起走。这是因为她把自己的病情怪罪在他身上。”与朋友商量后，马尔达维决定不再进一步参与阿努的计划。随着白天的继续，阿努坚持不懈杀死乔的消息在他们的朋友圈中传开。一个朋友威胁要报警，但阿努发现了并劝她打消了这个念头，向她保证她绝不会做任何伤害乔的事，并说：“我们已经订婚要结婚了。你可能会把我们所有人的事都毁了。”
Anu had a flair for drama, and many of her friends were familiar with her grandiose stories of illness and suicide. But as she had never gone through with self-harm, most remained convinced this was just another of her telltales. Anu admitted to those concerned that she had given Joe three rehypnal tablets, but insisted it was only to make sure he was asleep while she ended her own life. She convinced them that Joe was not in any danger and that she was going to confess to him about spiking his drink. In turn, the others agreed to let it go. At 10.19 that evening, Anu called a friend named Len who had attended the second dinner party. Len was fully aware of Anu's sinister plans, but had quashed the concerns of others by expressing
阿努有戏剧表演的天赋，她的许多朋友都很熟悉她那些关于生病和自杀的宏大故事。但由于她从未真正进行过自我伤害，大多数人仍然确信这只是她的又一个谎言。阿努向那些担心的人承认她给乔吃了三片瑞海普诺药片，但坚称这只是为了确保他在她结束自己生命时睡着。她向他们保证乔没有任何危险，并且她打算向他坦白她在他的饮料里下了药。反过来，其他人同意不再追究。当晚10点19分，阿努打电话给一位名叫伦的朋友，他参加了第二场晚宴。伦完全知道阿努的险恶计划，但通过表达
his opinion that the whole story was just a cry for attention. His answering machine recorded part of their conversation as Anu inquired how strong rehypnal was. She explained that Joe had slept for around 15 hours straight and was now groggy and struggling to keep his eyes open. She was worried about what she had done, but Len reassured her that she wouldn't have caused any long-term damage. Joe then took the phone from his girlfriend and said to Len, hey mate, my mind is 100% functional, my body just wants to sleep like crazy, that's all. She's worried for nothing. Shortly after midnight, Anu phoned another friend wanting to know if it was possible to shoot
他的看法，即整个故事只是一种博取关注的哭喊，打消了其他人的担忧。他的答录机录下了他们部分对话，当时阿努询问瑞海普诺有多强效。她解释说，乔已经连续睡了大约15个小时，现在昏昏沉沉，强睁着眼。她对自己的所作所为感到担心，但伦向她保证，她不会造成任何长期损害。随后，乔从女友手中接过电话，对伦说：“嘿，老兄，我的脑子100%好使，我的身体只是想疯狂地睡觉，就这样。她是在瞎担心。”午夜刚过，阿努给另一位朋友打电话，想知道是否有可能将
heroin into your legs or the back of your arms. The following morning of Sunday, October 26, 1997, Anu visited Mardavi and told her that Joe wasn't breathing and she needed money to buy heroin to take her own life. The pair drove to an ATM where Mardavi gave Anu $250 cash before walking home alone. At 9am, Anu arrived to her dealer's house and purchased half a gram of heroin. While it was being prepared in a syringe for her, she paced back and forth, repeatedly saying, today's the day. Between 9.13am and 9.40am, Anu phoned Mardavi several times. During one call, a housemate overheard Mardavi telling Anu to leave her alone, but she eventually caved and
海洛因注射进你的腿部或手臂背面。第二天，即1997年10月26日星期日，阿努拜访了马尔达维，告诉她乔没有呼吸了，她需要钱买海洛因来结束自己的生命。两人开车去了一台自动取款机，马尔达维给了阿努250美元现金，然后独自步行回家。上午9点，阿努到达她毒贩的家里，买下了半克海洛因。当毒贩为她将海洛因准备进注射器时，她来回踱步，反复念叨着：“就是今天了。”上午9点13分到9点40分之间，阿努多次打电话给马尔达维。在其中一次通话中，一位室友无意中听到马尔达维叫阿努别烦她，但她最终还是妥协了，
told Anu to come and pick her up. Soon after, the pair were witnessed having a heated conversation outside Mardavi's home, with Anu appearing to be very distressed. Approximately two hours later, Mardavi visited Len and informed him that after Joe awoke from his rehypnoll induced sleep the night before, he told Anu he was going to leave her. Mardavi then explained, Anu tried to kill Joe last night with heroin. She injected him with heroin. Up until this point, Len had been convinced the situation was a fanciful ploy, and was shocked to hear Anu had gone through with her plan. He suggested they call Anu's parents to tell them what happened, in case she later claimed Joe had taken the overdose himself.
叫阿努来接她。不久之后，有人目击两人在马尔达维家门外激烈交谈，阿努看起来非常痛苦。大约两个小时后，马尔达维拜访了伦，并告诉他，前一天晚上乔从瑞海普诺引起的睡眠中醒来后，他告诉阿努他要离开她。马尔达维接着解释说：“阿努昨晚试图用海洛因杀死乔。她给他注射了海洛因。”直到这一刻，伦还确信这种情况只是一个异想天开的把戏，听到阿努真的把她的计划付诸实施，他感到震惊。他建议他们打电话给阿努的父母，把发生的事情告诉他们，以防她以后声称乔是自己服药过量。
Concerned that Anu may turn up at his house to seek their help, Len and Mardavi went for a drive, during which Mardavi admitted she had visited 79 Antel Street earlier that morning and witnessed to Joe unconscious on the bed. He had still been breathing, but his skin was pale, and his lips had turned blue. As midday approached, Anu phoned the friend who had helped her obtain rehypnoll. Screaming frantically, she asked what the best course of action was for someone who had taken a heroin overdose. She was advised to call an ambulance, but Anu responded. I can't. He doesn't know. He'll be furious. She reported that Joe was taking one breath every 10 seconds, and was told to perform
担心阿努可能会出现在他家寻求他们的帮助，伦和马尔达维开车兜风，在此期间马尔达维承认她当天早上早些时候曾去过安特尔街79号，并亲眼目睹乔不省人事地躺在床上。他当时还在呼吸，但他的皮肤苍白，嘴唇变蓝了。临近中午，阿努打电话给那个帮她获取瑞海普诺的朋友。她疯狂地尖叫，询问对于海洛因过量的人来说，最好的处理方法是什么。她被建议叫救护车，但阿努回答说：“我不能。他不知道。他会大发雷霆的。”她报告说乔每10秒呼吸一次，并被告知进行
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation. Anu put the phone down and returned a few seconds later to report that Joe was vomiting black liquid. Her friend repeatedly told her to call an ambulance, but Anu responded. It's too late. He's gone anyway. Her friend warned her that if she didn't call the paramedics, she could have a murder charge on her hands. At this point, Anu disconnected their call. At 12.10 pm, she placed a call to the emergency services hotline, requesting ambulance assistance to treat a potential heroin overdose. She was hysterical and evasive, and refused to answer the dispatcher's repeated requests
人工呼吸。阿努放下电话，几秒钟后回来报告说乔在吐黑水。她的朋友多次叫她叫救护车，但阿努回答说：“太迟了。他已经走了。”她的朋友警告她，如果她不叫急救人员，她可能会面临谋杀指控。此时，阿努挂断了他们的电话。下午12点10分，她拨打了紧急服务热线，要求派救护车治疗可能的海洛因过量。她歇斯底里且闪烁其词，拒绝回答调度员的多次请求
for her address. Anu finally gave the address of 30 Antle Street, before changing it to number 79. The dispatcher urged her to calm down. When asked for her name, Anu repeatedly replied Olivia between sobs and profanities. The dispatcher instructed her to provide mouth-to-mouth resuscitation to the victim, but Anu explained there was too much blood coming out of his mouth and his teeth wouldn't open. She pleaded, what am I doing? He'll be all right, won't he? Oh God, I can't. I can't. Although the ambulance dispatch station was only one kilometer from Joe and Anu's townhouse on
询问她的地址。阿努终于给出了安特尔街30号的地址，随后又将其改为了79号。调度员敦促她冷静下来。当被问及她的名字时，阿努在抽泣和说脏话的同时多次回答“奥利维亚”。调度员指示她对受害者进行人工呼吸，但阿努解释说有太多血从他嘴里涌出来，他的牙齿张不开。她恳求道：“我在干什么？他会没事的，对吧？哦天哪，我不能。我不能。”尽管救护车调度站距离乔和阿努在
Antle Street, it took paramedics eight minutes to arrive due to the evasive answers she gave to the emergency hotline. When they arrived, Anu ran onto the street and waved them down. Her dark hair was in a loose bun and her white dress was streaked with brown stains. She directed them inside and into a bedroom, where Joe was lying diagonally across the bed, naked from the waist down. His stomach was bloated and dark brown vomit was caked around his mouth. Despite the paramedics' efforts, he could not be resuscitated. Anu begged them to keep trying, throwing herself on Joe's body and sobbing. You have to bring him back. It wasn't supposed to happen this way. We were supposed to go together.
安特尔街的联排别墅只有一公里，但由于她对紧急热线给出了 evasive（含糊其辞）的回答，急救人员花了八分钟才到达。他们到达时，阿努跑上街头向他们挥手。她的黑头发盘成了一个松散的发髻，白裙子上带有棕色的污渍。她把他们领进屋内，带进一间卧室，乔斜躺在床上，腰部以下赤裸。他的腹部肿胀，嘴周围结了一层深棕色的呕吐物。尽管急救人员尽了最大努力，他还是没能被抢救过来。阿努恳求他们继续尝试，扑在乔的尸体上痛哭流涕。“你们必须把他救回来。事情本不该这样的。我们本该一起走的。”
Police were summoned to the scene, where they found Anu rocking back and forth, cradling Joe's body. They physically removed her from the bedroom and commenced questioning, during which Anu explained that she had given Joe four rehypnal tablets and had also taken some herself. She then injected herself and Joe with heroin, saying, I just kept pumping it into him to put him to sleep, so he wouldn't be awake when I killed myself. Anu Singh was promptly placed under arrest for murder and taken into custody. The Chinque family were informed of Joe's death later that evening. In the book Joe Chinque's Consolation by Helen Garner, Maria Chinque said that when they were
警察被召集到现场，发现阿努前后摇晃，怀里抱着乔的尸体。他们强行将她从卧室里拉出来并开始审讯，在审讯过程中，阿努解释说她给了乔四片瑞海普诺药片，自己也吃了一些。然后她给自己和乔注射了海洛因，并说：“我只是不断地把它打进他体内让他睡着，这样自我自杀时他就不会醒着了。”阿努·辛格随即因谋杀罪被捕并被拘留。当天傍晚晚些时候，钦克韦一家收到了乔的死讯。在海伦·加纳所著的书《乔·钦克韦的慰藉》中，玛丽亚·钦克韦说，当他们
told a woman had been charged with Joe's murder, they immediately knew Anu was involved. Her youngest son, Anthony, punched a hole through a door, exclaiming, that bitch has killed my brother. Autopsy and toxicology reports confirmed Joe Chinque died as a result of asphyxiation while under the influence of heroin and rehypnal, both of which were respiratory depressants. The typical concentration of heroin found in the body of an overdose victim was between 0.2 and 0.5 milligrams per litre, and the amount in Joe's system was 0.67 milligrams per litre. The police seized the Joe's daily planner and discovered he had entered an appointment for
得知一名女性因谋杀乔而被起诉时，他们立刻就知道阿努牵涉其中。她的小儿子安东尼一拳打穿了一扇门，大喊道：“那个贱人杀了我哥哥。”尸检和毒理学报告证实，乔·钦克韦死于在海洛因和瑞海普诺的影响下窒息，这两种药物都是呼吸抑制剂。在过量吸毒受害者体内发现的典型海洛因浓度在每升0.2到0.5毫克之间，而乔体内系统中的含量为每升0.67毫克。警方查获了乔的日程规划本，发现他在
2 p.m. on Monday, October 27, two days after the second dinner party, which read, get ready to move. He had drawn an arrow to 6 p.m. riding alongside it, move urgent, today. When the Chinque's visited Joe's house following his death, they were unable to find any of his luggage. This, coupled with the diary entry, led them to believe that Joe had intended to leave Anu. Police executed a search warrant at the home of Anu's best friend, Mardavi Rao. In her bedroom, they found a packet of rehypnal, used syringe packs, alcohol swabs, and several pamphlets about drugs, veins, and arteries. They also found Anu's torn-up diary in her rubbish bin.
10月27日星期一（第二场晚宴两天后）下午2点写下了一个预约，上面写着：“准备搬家”。他画了一个箭头指向下午6点，并在旁边写着：“紧急搬家，今天”。当钦克韦一家在乔死后访问他的家时，他们找不到他的任何行李。这与日记条目相结合，使他们相信乔原本打算离开阿努。警方对阿努最好的朋友马尔达维·拉奥的家执行了搜查令。在她的卧室里，他们找到了包装好的瑞海普诺、用过的注射器包装盒、酒精棉片以及几本关于毒品、静脉和动脉的小册子。他们还在她的垃圾桶里找到了被撕碎的阿努的日记。
Mardavi was taken to the police station, and for her involvement in the crime, was also charged with the murder of Joe Chinque, along with attempted murder, unlawful and felonious slaying, and administering a stupefying drug. In response to the charges, Mardavi said, I tried at every stage to intercede. Three days later, her parents secured her $100,000 bail, and she was released on the condition that she remained under their supervision at their home in Sydney. Anu and Mardavi were scheduled to be tried together a year later, with Anu held in custody
马尔达维被带到警察局，因其在犯罪中的涉案程度，也被指控谋杀乔·钦克韦，罪名还包括谋杀未遂、非法和重罪杀戮以及施用麻醉药物。针对这些指控，马尔达维说：“我在每个阶段都试图干预。”三天后，她的父母为她担保了10万美元的保释金，她被释放，条件是她留在悉尼家中接受他们的监督。阿努和马尔达维原定于一年后一起接受审判，阿努在候审期间
while awaiting trial. From the Remand Center where she was incarcerated, she phoned a friend and requested he bring her all the relevant High Court cases where the defendant had successfully pleaded not guilty due to reasons of insanity. The duo's joint trial commenced at Canberra's Supreme Court on Tuesday, October 6, 1998, before Justice Ken Crispin. Anu pleaded not guilty to Joe's murder for reason of diminished responsibility. This meant she accepted she had broken the law, but should not be held criminally liable as her mental functioning was impaired when the crime occurred. She claimed she was suffering from untreated borderline personality disorder and major
被关押在拘留中心。从她被关押的审前拘留中心，她打电话给一位朋友，请求他给她带来所有相关的最高法院案例，即被告因精神失常原因成功抗辩无罪的案例。这两人于1998年10月6日星期二在堪培拉最高法院出庭受审，主审法官是肯·克里斯平法官。阿努以责任能力减弱为由，对乔的谋杀指控作出了无罪抗辩。这意味着她承认自己触犯了法律，但由于犯罪时她的精神功能受损，不应承担刑事责任。她声称自己患有未治疗的边缘型人格障碍和重度
depressive disorder, which was characterized by self-destructive behavior, explosive anger, self-harm, distorted self-image, unstable relationships, fear of abandonment, chronic feelings of emptiness, and having a false sense of reality. The friend who had supplied Anu with the heroin she used to kill Joe was granted immunity in exchange for providing evidence against the two accused in court. Numerous witnesses testified to knowing about Anu's plans to carry out a murder suicide and said that Mardavi had assisted her. The defense team tried to use these admissions against the witnesses by questioning why they didn't intervene, and many struggled to offer an
抑郁症，其特征是自残行为、爆发性愤怒、自残、扭曲的自我形象、不稳定的关系、对被抛弃的恐惧、慢性的空虚感以及虚幻的现实感。曾向阿努提供用于杀死乔的海洛因的朋友获得了豁免权，换取在法庭上指证两名被告的证据。许多证人作证说知道阿努实施谋杀自杀的计划，并表示马尔达维曾协助她。辩护团队试图利用这些供词来质问证人为什么不进行干预，许多人难以给出
explanation. During the fourth week of the trial, it became apparent to Justice Crispin that the evidence accumulating against Anu would likely cause unfair prejudice against her co-accused. He terminated the proceedings, ordering Anu and Mardavi to face separate trials at a later date. The prosecution then offered Anu the option of pleading guilty to manslaughter in exchange for a reduced sentence, but she refused, maintaining her innocence. While awaiting her second trial, a letter written by Anu was seized from her locker. It began. I have decided to write down how this happened, to get it clear in my mind also. She went on to describe all of the events that led to Joe's death, starting from when she and
解释。在审判的第四周，克里斯平法官显然看出针对阿努不断累积的证据可能会对她的共同被告造成不公平的偏见。他终止了诉讼程序，下令让阿努和马尔达维在稍后的日期分别面对审判。随后，检方为阿努提供了承认过失杀人以换取减刑的选项，但她拒绝了，坚信自己无罪。在等待第二次审判期间，从她的储物柜中查获了一封由阿努写的信。信的开头写道：“我决定写下这一切是如何发生的，以便在我的脑海中也把它理清楚。”她接着描述了导致乔死亡的所有事件，从她和
Mardavi visited the library to photocopy information about suicide. She said she had initially intended to end her own life, but after reading stories about partners who remarried a year or two after the suicide of a loved one, she decided it was only fair that Joe die with her. From then, all she thought about was death. Anu wrote, Didn't I think at the time that these friends of mine were helping me to die? Didn't I stop and think then that Joe was helping me to live? No. I felt compelled to do it because I thought everyone was against me and only cared if Joe died or not. Then I wasn't sure whether to call the ambulance, because Mardavi said if you call
马尔达维去图书馆复印关于自杀的信息开始。她说她最初打算结束自己的生命，但在读到关于伴侣在所爱之人自杀一两年后又再婚的故事后，她决定让乔和她一起死才算公平。从那时起，她脑子里想的就只有死亡。阿努写道：“难道我当时没想过我的这些朋友是在帮我去死吗？难道我当时没有停下来想一想乔是在帮我活下来吗？没有。我觉得自己被迫这样做，因为我认为所有人都反对我，只有在乔死的时候才会在乎。”然后我不确定是否应该叫救护车，因为马尔达维说如果你打电话
the ambulance he will leave you and put you in an institution. In another letter addressed to her mother, Anu wrote, The most wonderful man in the world loved me so much would have made a perfect husband and father. Ruined. Perfect life. Ruined. Now everyone is better off than me when I had it all. I bet everyone is laughing at me now because of my own utter stupidity and selfishness. You must start preparing for my death now. My life is over. I made the wrong choice when so many others were available at the time. Worked with the drugies rather than Joe. Should have protected him and worked with him. Now so many lives are ruined. I wish these drugies were dead and not Joe. Not Joe. Mum. Please not Joe.
救护车会带走你，把你关进精神病院。在写给她母亲的另一封信中，阿努写道：世界上最 maravilhoso 的男人曾那样深爱我，他本可以成为一个完美的丈夫和父亲。全毁了。完美的生活。全毁了。现在每个人都过得比我好，而我曾拥有这一切。我敢说，现在大家一定都在因为我自己的愚蠢和自私而嘲笑我。你现在必须开始为我的死做准备了。我的一生完了。当时明明有那么多选择，我却做出了错误的选择。我应该和那些瘾君子合作，而不是乔。我本该保护他、和他合作。现在这么多人的生活都被毁了。我希望死的是那些瘾君子，而不是乔。不是乔。妈妈。求求你，不要是乔。
Anu's solo trial commenced on Monday, March 22, 1999. This time there was no jury present and she was tried by judge alone. In support of Anu's plea of not guilty, forensic psychologist Dr. Kenneth Byrne testified. He stated that Anu had been suffering from severe depression and borderline personality disorder since her teens and was lost in a delusional world where she truly believed she was going to die from a degenerative disease. His diagnosis was bolstered by professor of forensic psychology Paul Mullen who said that Anu was suffering from a significant depressive illness throughout 1997 which culminated in Joe Chinque's death. Consultant psychiatrist to Dr. Fatma Loden who had spent an extended period of time speaking
阿努的单独审判于1999年3月22日星期一正式开始。这一次没有陪审团在场，而是由法官独自审理。为了支持阿努无罪的抗辩，法医心理学家肯尼斯·伯恩博士出庭作证。他作证称，阿努从青少年时期起就患有严重的抑郁症和边缘型人格障碍，迷失在一个她坚信自己会死于退行性疾病的妄想世界中。法医心理学教授保罗·穆伦的证词进一步印证了他的诊断，保罗表示阿努在1997年全年都患有严重的抑郁症，这最终导致了乔·钦奎的死亡。曾花大量时间与阿努交谈的顾问精神病学家法特马·洛登博士
with Anu in custody also supported this diagnosis adding that Anu's personality disorder was exacerbated by her bulimia and substance abuse. Had she accepted treatment earlier, Dr. Loden believed Anu's mental state would have improved dramatically. She recommended the accused be spared jail and instead be hospitalized for up to six months to undergo psychiatric treatment followed with five years of medication and seven years of psychotherapy. The prosecution argued that Anu's actions were not impacted by her mental state and that she was perfectly capable of making rational decisions at the time of Joe's death. This was supported by her decision to wait before calling an ambulance along with the intentionally evasive and misleading
在拘留所里，她也支持这一诊断，并补充说阿努的人格障碍因其贪食症和物质滥用而加剧。洛登博士认为，如果阿努早点接受治疗，她的精神状态本会有戏剧性的改善。她建议免除被告的监禁，改为将其送入医院接受长达六个月的精神科治疗，随后进行五年的药物治疗和七年的心理治疗。检方辩称，阿努的行为并未受到其精神状态的影响，在乔去世时，她完全有能力做出理性的决定。这一点得到了她决定在叫救护车前先等待的举动的支持，此外她在向紧急服务调度员提供信息时，还带有故意逃避和误导的性质，
answers she gave the emergency services dispatcher as though she was hindering efforts to save Joe's life. They argued that if Anu was as depressed as psychologists believed she would have killed herself after Joe as per her alleged plan. Her torn up diary found in Mardavi's rubbish bin had been painstakingly pieced back together and the prosecution believed it displayed a looming vendetta against Joe. They asserted the entries were rational and didn't exhibit any indication of mental illness. On the contrary they showed that Anu was capable of developing and maintaining normal intimate relationships and friendships. Quoting Anu's own statement that she had watched Joe die and didn't save him the prosecution asked. Why is that a psychiatric illness?
她给出的回答就像是在阻挠拯救乔生命的努力。他们辩称，如果阿努真的像心理学家认为的那样抑郁，她本会按照她所谓的计划在乔死后自杀。她在马达维的垃圾桶里被撕碎的日记被费力地拼凑了回来，检方认为这显示了她对乔蓄谋已久的报复。他们断言这些日记条目是理性的，没有任何精神疾病的迹象。相反，它们表明阿努有能力建立并维持正常的亲密关系和友谊。检方引用阿努自己的陈述——她看着乔死去却没有救他——质问法庭：这怎么能算是一种精神疾病？
Wasn't she just a very selfish young woman? The letters penned by Anu during her time in custody were used as evidence that she considered her actions deliberate selfish and wrong further proving she was of rational mind. Various witnesses who described Anu in such terms as dramatic outgoing psycho and fixated stated their belief that she appeared healthy and they therefore never believed her when she said she intended to kill herself. The prosecution's argument was supported by psychiatrist Dr Michael Diamond. He concluded that Anu was of sound mind when she murdered Joe and that her problem lay in a lack of maturity which impaired her ability to handle complex emotions, control her moods and rationally
她难道不是一个极其自私的年轻女性吗？阿努在被拘留期间写下的信件被用作证据，证明她认为自己的行为是蓄意的、自私的和错误的，这进一步证明她当时头脑清醒。多位证人将阿努形容为富有戏剧性、性格外向、有精神病倾向且执拗，他们表示自己认为她看起来很健康，因此当她说她打算自杀时，他们从不相信她。检方的主张得到了精神病学家迈克尔·戴蒙德博士的支持。他得出结论认为，阿努在谋杀乔时神志清醒，她的问题在于缺乏成熟度，这削弱了她处理复杂情感、控制情绪和理性解决冲突的能力。
resolve conflict. The fact that she had called a friend seeking advice to try and reverse what she had done was evidence that she wanted to avoid trouble with the authorities. Dr Diamond quote. The whole scheme with its support roles and a large cast of extras had been a tremendous drama she was staging part of her narcissistic need to be taken seriously and helped. She derived so much gratification from being at the center of this drama that the point was not to commit suicide. Forensic toxicologist Professor Olof Drummer testified that he was not certain how often Anu had administered the heroin to Joe as the level of the drug in his body was so high that it could have come from a large single dose or an accumulation of smaller doses.
她打电话给朋友寻求建议以试图逆转她所做的事情，这一事实证明她想要逃避法律的惩罚。戴蒙德博士原话：“整个计划及其配角和一大群临时演员，是一场她一手导演的巨大悲剧，这体现了她希望被认真对待和帮助的自恋需求。她从处于这场戏剧的中心获得了巨大的满足感，以至于重点根本不是去自杀。”法医毒理学家奥洛夫·德拉姆查教授出庭作证称，他无法确定阿努给乔注射海洛因的频率，因为他体内的药物浓度极高，可能来自单次大剂量注射，也可能是多次小剂量注射的积累。
But he believed Joe was likely given one injection at approximately 3 a.m. on Sunday, October 26, 1997 and to then inject it again about eight hours later, explaining. On an opiate naive person like Joe Chinquay any fair size the dose of heroin would have a powerful effect and combined with rehypno it would be even more likely to kill him. A victim impact statement prepared by Maria Chinquay was read silently by Justice Crispin who didn't disclose its contents to the packed courthouse. At the completion of the trial Justice Crispin acknowledged the profound challenge this case presented. While he was satisfied beyond reasonable doubt that Anu intended to cause Joe's death
但他相信，乔很可能是在1997年10月26日星期日凌晨3点左右被注射了一次，大约八小时后再注射一次。他解释说：“对于像乔·钦奎这样没有阿片类药物耐受力的人来说，相当剂量的海洛因都会产生强大的药效，如果再加上氟硝西泮（rehypnol），那就更可能致死。”由玛丽亚·钦奎准备的一份受害人影响陈述书被克里斯平法官默默地阅读了，他并未向挤满人的法庭公开其内容。庭审结束时，克里斯平法官承认本案带来了极大的挑战。虽然他确信无疑地认为阿努意图导致乔的死亡，
he accepted she was suffering from quote an abnormality of mind that substantially impaired her mental ability making it impossible to know what she was thinking at the time or what caused her to take such actions. The case had captured national interest and on Thursday, June 24, 1999 camera crews and journalists lined the staircases of the courthouse eager to hear the verdict. The Chinquay family sat in the front row with Maria crying silently into a handkerchief. The proceedings had left them in a state of disbelief. They were unable to accept that so many people had passively died with their son knowing full well that his death was imminent and had chosen not to warn him or contact authorities.
但他接受了以下说法：阿努患有“精神异常，严重损害了她的精神能力，使得当时无法得知她在想什么或是什么导致她采取了这种行为”。此案引起了全国的关注。1999年6月24日星期四，摄像机和记者排满了法院的楼梯，渴望听到判决结果。钦奎一家坐在前排，玛丽亚默默地对着手帕哭泣。诉讼程序让他们陷入了难以置信的状态。他们无法接受的是，竟然有这么多人眼睁睁地看着他们的儿子死去，明知他的死已迫在眉睫，却选择不警告他或联系当局。
Justice Crispin addressed Anu directly saying, in the next few years you will have come to terms with the fact that you killed the man you loved. You have caused immense pain. If you find the moral courage you may be able to rebuild from this wreckage to repay the trust people have put in you. He then declared her not guilty of Joe Chinquay's murder but guilty to manslaughter on the grounds of diminished responsibility. Anu Singh was sentenced to 10 years in prison with a non-parole period of four years backdated to the time of Joe's death. This meant she would be eligible for release in a little over two years. The short sentence devastated the Chinquay family. When Justice Crispin left the
克里斯平法官直接向阿努发表讲话，他说：“在接下来的几年里，你将不得不接受这样一个事实：你杀死了你所爱的男人。你带来了巨大的痛苦。如果你能找到道德勇气，你或许能够从这片废墟中重建自我，回报人们对你的信任。”随后，他宣布她谋杀乔·钦奎的罪名不成立，但因责任能力减弱，过失杀人罪成立。阿努·辛格被判处10年监禁，其中4年为不得假释期，并从乔去世的时间算起。这意味着她在略多于两年后就有资格获得假释。短刑期让钦奎一家心碎欲绝。当克里斯平法官离开
courtroom, Maria turned to Anu and yelled, This is where you belong. You stay forever. Rot in hell you bitch. Devil. She's a demon. My son. That's all. Four years. How can you sleep at night? Four years. Is that all my son is worth? Outside the courthouse, Maria told the gathering media that Anu should have been sentenced to death by hanging. Maria's outrage was echoed by the public who believed Anu had successfully fooled the court into getting away with murder. There was widespread doubt over the extent her mental illness played on her actions and many were of the opinion that she would have received a much harsher sentence had she been trialled by a jury who would have had a more emotional response
法庭时，玛丽亚转身对阿努大喊：“这里才是你该呆的地方。你永远呆在这吧。在地狱里腐烂吧，贱人。恶魔。她是个恶魔。我的儿子。就只有这些。四年。你怎么能夜夜安眠？四年。我的儿子就只值这点钱吗？”在法院外，玛丽亚对聚集的媒体表示，阿努应该被判处绞刑。公众对玛丽亚的愤怒表示共鸣，他们认为阿努成功地愚弄了法庭，逃脱了谋杀罪的惩罚。对于她的精神疾病在多大程度上影响了她的行为，各界存在广泛的怀疑，许多人认为，如果是由陪审团审判，由于陪审团会对案件产生更多情感反应，她本会受到严厉得多的惩罚。
to the case. In Justice Crispin's sentencing report, he wrote, The events which have led to this case have been tragic. Mr Chinquay was an intelligent, well-educated and handsome young man of 26 who was obviously devoted to the prisoner and looking forward to sharing his life with her. There has been no suggestion that the actions which caused his death were in any way provoked by his conduct. On the contrary, it seems clear that he had faithfully supported the prisoner through very difficult times. She herself referred to him as the most wonderful man in the world. Yet, despite these qualities and his undoubted love for her, she killed him. She did so deliberately. Her actions were premeditated and involved
在克里斯平法官的量刑报告中，他写道：“导致本案的事件是一场悲剧。钦奎先生是一名26岁聪明、受过良好教育且英俊的年轻男子，他显然深爱着被告，并期待着与她分享生活。没有任何迹象表明导致他死亡的行为是由他的品行引起的。相反，很明显，他在非常困难的时期一直忠实地支持着被告。她自己称他为世界上最美妙的男人。然而，尽管他拥有这些特质并且无疑深爱着她，她还是杀了他。她是蓄意这么做的。她的行为是预谋的，并且涉及
some significant planning. There were no extenuating circumstances other than her own mental state and she was acquitted of murder only upon grounds of diminished responsibility. Were it not for her diminished responsibility, the crime would obviously have warranted a very heavy sentence of imprisonment. Mardavi Rao's judge only trial began six months later on Friday, December 10, 1999. She pleaded not guilty to the four charges against her. Murder, attempted murder, unlawful and felonious slaying and administering a stupefying drug. The prosecution clarified they didn't believe Mardavi had caused Jo Chin Kuei's death but was criminally responsible for Anu's actions by aiding and debating her in offences she knew were
一些重大的策划。除了她自己的精神状态外，没有任何情有可原的情节，她仅因责任能力减弱而被判谋杀罪不成立。若不是因为她的责任能力减弱，这起罪行显然理应招致非常重的监禁刑罚。”马达维·拉奥由法官独自审理的庭审在六个月后的1999年12月10日星期五开始。她对针对她的四项指控进行了无罪抗辩：谋杀、企图谋杀、非法和重罪杀戮以及施用麻醉药物。检方澄清说，他们不认为马达维造成了乔·钦奎的死亡，但她因协助和教唆阿努实施她明知
intended to end his life. As Mardavi was fully aware of Anu's plot to kill Jo, they said she had failed her duty of care to save him. The prosecution believed Mardavi was present when Anu spiked to Jo's drink with rehypnol after the second dinner party and that the two women had likely given him the first injection of heroin thereafter but it failed to result in his death. Mardavi's defense lawyer put forward that his client could not be convicted of administering a stupefying drug as it couldn't be proven what time Jo was injected with the lethal dose of heroin. He argued that Mardavi's duty of care ended on the morning of Sunday, October 26 when she told Anu that she no longer wanted anything to do with the plan. When she saw Jo ill in his
意在结束他生命的犯罪行为，而对阿努的行为负有刑事责任。由于马达维完全清楚阿努杀死乔的计划，他们表示她未能履行保护他的注意义务。检方认为，在第二次晚宴后，当阿努在乔的饮料中下氟硝西泮时，马达维在场，并且这两名女性此后很可能给乔注射了第一剂海洛因，但该注射未能导致他的死亡。马达维的辩护律师提出，他的客户不能被判定犯有施用麻醉药物罪，因为无法证明乔被注射致死量海洛因的具体时间。他辩称，马达维的注意义务在10月26日星期日早晨结束了，当时她告诉阿努她不再想与这个计划有任何瓜葛。当她看到乔生病躺在
bedroom, she no longer had a duty of care as they were associated by friendship only and not by marriage or family. Justice Crispin interjected, asking, isn't it a rather chilling concept that one could take part in a plan to kill somebody, go out and buy the drugs for the job, and then say simply, I'm washing my hands of it now, I've got no responsibility, let him die. The defense maintained that Mardavi had no more legal culpability than a complete stranger or innocent bystander. Numerous witnesses testified that Mardavi was alarmingly passive in her friendship with Anu and that she went to unhealthy lengths to put her best friend's needs ahead of her own. Mardavi was described as warm, gentle and eager to please. She therefore had difficulty
卧室里时，她已不再负有注意义务，因为他们仅因朋友关系相连，而非婚姻或家庭关系。克里斯平法官插话问道：“难道这不是一个相当令人不寒而栗的概念吗？一个人可以参与杀死某人的计划，出去为这项工作买毒品，然后简单地说，‘我现在要洗手不干了，我没有责任，让他去死吧。’”辩护方坚持认为，马达维的法律过错并不比一个完全的陌生人或无辜的旁观者更多。多位证人作证说，马达维在她与阿努的友谊中惊人地被动，她为了将最好朋友的需求置于自己之上，付出了不健康的代价。马达维被描述为一个热情、温柔且渴望取悦他人的人。
standing up for herself and to let the far more dominant Anu take advantage of her. At one stage, at one stage, she told a classmate, I've got a friend who's suicidal, she smothers me. A prison welfare officer testified that during Mardavi's short time in custody before securing bail, she overheard Anu putting the pressure on Mardavi to get their story straight. Later, Mardavi confided in the welfare officer about why she went along with the news plan. She explained that she had a sister with a disability and would never have been able to forgive herself for abandoning Anu if she discovered she really did have a serious degenerative illness. According to the defense, the lack of clear evidence confirming exactly what had happened
因此，她很难坚持自我，并任由远比她强势的阿努占她的便宜。在某个阶段，她曾对一个同班同学说：“我有一个有自杀倾向的朋友，她把我压得透不过气来。”一名监狱福利官作证说，在马达维获得保释前的短暂羁押期间，她无意中听到阿努向马达维施压，要求她们统一口径。后来，马达维向福利官吐露了她为何顺从阿努计划的原因。她解释说，她有一个残疾的姐姐，如果她发现阿努真的患有严重的退行性疾病而自己却抛弃了她，她将永远无法原谅自己。根据辩护方的说法，缺乏清晰的证据来确切证实乔死前发生的事情，
in the lead-up to Joe's death meant it would be unreasonable to convict their client on any charges. On Friday, December 20, Justice Crispin accepted this viewpoint and declared Mardavi not guilty of all four charges. He concluded that although her behaviour was suspicious, the evidence was not indisputably deeming. It was undeniable she was aware that Joe was in danger, but this didn't prove she shared Anu's criminal intent or aided her in causing his death. In addition, Justice Crispin couldn't discount the possibility that Mardavi was going along with Anu's plan with the intention of persuading her to change her mind, or was too timid to intervene. He also acknowledged Mardavi may have thought the whole scheme was
意味着根据任何罪名对他们的客户定罪都是不合理的。1999年12月20日星期星期五，克里斯平法官接受了这一观点，并宣布马达维的四项指控全部不成立。他得出结论，尽管她的行为令人怀疑，但证据并不是无可置疑的。无可否认她知道乔处于危险之中，但这并不证明她与阿努有共同的犯罪意图，也没有证明她协助阿努导致了乔的死亡。此外，克里斯平法官不能排除这样一种可能性：马达维顺从阿努的计划是出于说服她改变主意的目的，或者是因为她太过胆怯而不敢干涉。他还承认，马达维可能认为整个计划
just another one of Anu's melodramatic plans that would never come to fruition. and Anu's melodramatic plans that would never come to fruition. Maria and Nino Chinque yelled in protest and had to be escorted out of the court. Later that evening, Nino collapsed and was rushed to hospital where he underwent treatment for heart problems. Of Mardavi's verdict, Anu Singh later said, It's my fault entirely. I was hysterical and she just loved me and wanted to help me. What would sending her to jail have really done? Would it have eased Maria and Nino's pain anymore? It seems it's perpetuating sorrow on so many people. Her family would have suffered as my
只是阿努又一个永远不会实现的夸张计划之一。玛丽亚和尼诺·钦奎愤怒地大喊抗议，并被护送出法庭。当天晚些时候，尼诺晕倒并被紧急送往医院，在那里他接受了心脏问题的治疗。对于马达维的判决，阿努·辛格后来表示：“这完全是我的错。我当时情绪失控，而她只是爱我并想帮我。把她送进监狱真的能起到什么作用吗？这能减轻玛丽亚和尼诺的痛苦吗？这似乎只是在给这么多人延续悲伤。她的家人会像我的家人一样痛苦。”我没有把任何责任推给马达维。
family suffered. I don't put any blame on Mardavi. Anu served her sentence at the Silverwater Correctional Complex, a maximum security prison 20 kilometers west of the Sydney CBD, where she worked in the prison library and tutored other inmates. She underwent psychotherapy and was prescribed with medication used to treat a range of mental health issues, including depression, anxiety and obsessive compulsive disorder. She was eventually transferred to the Emu Claims Correctional Center and granted day release to attend classes at the University of Sydney, where she obtained a master's in criminology. In October of 2001, she was released on parole at the age of 29. In 2004, she breached her parole
阿努在悉尼中央商务区以西20公里的最高安全级别监狱——西尔沃沃特惩教中心服刑，她在监狱图书馆工作并辅导其他犯人。她接受了心理治疗，并被开具了用于治疗一系列心理健康问题的药物，包括抑郁症、焦虑症和强迫症。她最终被转到埃姆克莱姆斯惩教中心，并获准日间释放以参加悉尼大学的课程，在那里她获得了犯罪学硕士学位。2001年10月，29岁的她获得假释出狱。2004年，她违反了假释
conditions by smoking cannabis and served an additional three months in jail. In 2009, Anu was awarded a doctorate by the University of Sydney's Law Faculty after completing a thesis titled Offending Women Toward a Greater Understanding of Women's Pathways Into and Out of Crime in Australia. She has since admitted that she lied in 1997 when she told a university counselor that Joe had been abusive towards her. In a 2004 interview with ABC News, she said that although Joe had expressed frustration that Anu was no longer the happy and friendly person he had first met in 1995, he never indicated that he intended to leave her. She discussed her suicidal thoughts with him and he encouraged her to persevere with life. When asked why she killed Joe,
条件，因吸食大麻而在监狱里多服刑了三个月。2009年，阿努完成了题为《犯罪女性：更深入了解女性走向犯罪与脱离犯罪的途径（澳大利亚）》的论文，并被悉尼大学法学院授予博士学位。她后来承认，自己在1997年对大学辅导员说乔虐待她时撒了谎。在2004年接受澳大利亚广播公司新闻采访时，她表示，尽管乔曾对阿努不再是1995年刚见面时那个快乐友善的人表达过沮丧，但他从未表示过打算离开她。她曾与他讨论过自己的自杀倾向，而他鼓励她坚持生活。当被问及她为什么杀死乔时，
Anu stated, there's absolutely no legitimate or rational motivation at all. Anu now lives in Sydney and is in a long-term relationship with a fellow inmate she met during her time on Remand. She accepts full responsibility for Joe's death. Mardavi Rao changed her name and moved to the United States where she lives with her husband and children. Many of their classmates and friends who attended the dinner parties and failed to notify authorities of Anu's plan to murder Joe went on to practice law. The townhouse on Antle Street that Anu and Joe shared has since been demolished to make way for a new government housing project. For many years, Joe's childhood bedroom at his parents' house
阿努表示：“绝对没有任何合乎逻辑或理性的动机。”阿努目前住在悉尼，与她在还押候审期间认识的一名同案犯保持着长期的恋爱关系。她为乔的死承担全部责任。马达维·拉奥改了名字并搬到了美国，与她的丈夫和孩子生活在一起。参加了晚宴且未将阿努谋杀乔的计划通知当局的许多同学和朋友后来都从事了法律工作。阿努和乔曾共同居住的安特尔街联排别墅此后已被拆除，以便为政府的新住房项目让路。多年来，乔在父母家中的童年卧室
in Newcastle remained untouched. His single bed sat underneath a wall plastered with posters and photos alongside an exercise bike, a brown desk and a shelf piled with books. The Chinquays are still unable to grasp why Mardavi nor any of the others had come to Joe's aid. Nino Chinquay told ABC News, Why you don't call the ambulance? Why you don't call the police when you see a person dying? If you see a dog on the street from a car accident, you call somebody to help the bloody dog. It's a man dying. Why you don't call the ambulance? Joe Chinquay's death is often cited as an example of the bystander effect,
位于纽卡斯尔的房间一直保持原样。他的单人床摆在贴满海报和照片的墙壁下方，旁边是一辆健身单车、一张棕色书桌和一个堆满书的书架。钦奎一家仍然无法理解为什么马达维或其他人没有来施救乔。尼诺·钦奎告诉澳大利亚广播公司新闻：“为什么不叫救护车？当你看到一个人在死时，为什么不叫警察？如果你在街上看到一只因车祸受伤的狗，你会叫人来帮这只可怜的狗。这是一个快要死的人。为什么不叫救护车？”乔·钦奎的死经常被引为旁观者效应的例子，
a social psychological claim that individuals are less likely to help someone in need when others are present. Filmmaker Satiri Danukas explored this theme in his 2016 movie titled Joe Chinquay's Consolation based on Helen Garner's 2004 book of the same name. He told Vice Magazine, The narrative is so extreme you ask yourself, how could this occur? Even with what you might know about the individuals, we're talking about the execution of someone, a life being blacked off the face of the earth. These people wanted to go to these dinner parties and to their own inner dialogue said, this has nothing to do with me. And yet the act of being spectators maintained a news momentum that gave her an audience. To a narcissist, an audience is part of the air that
这是一种社会心理学主张，即当周围有其他人时，个人不太可能去帮助有需要的人。电影制片人萨蒂里·达努卡斯在他的2016年电影《乔·钦奎的慰藉》（改编自海伦·加纳2004年的同名书）中探讨了这一主题。他告诉《Vice》杂志：“这个叙事极端到你会问自己，这怎么可能发生？即使结合你对这些个人的了解，我们谈论的是对一个人的处决，一个生命从地球上被抹去。这些人想去参加这些晚宴，并在他们自己的内心独白中说，这与我无关。然而，作为旁观者的行为维持了阿努的势头，为她提供了一个观众。对于一个自恋者来说，观众就是他们呼吸的空气的一部分。”
they breathe. In 2017, Anu appeared on Australian television current affairs program Sunday night and made a public apology to the Chinquay family, stating, there are many things people don't understand. There's a lot of things that have been overlooked. I was suffering from a very, very severe mental illness at the time. If I could have listened to people and sought the right sort of mental help, this wouldn't have happened. I would like to say to Maria and to Nino that I am deeply, deeply sorry for what happened and to that if I could, if there was any way I could turn back the clock, I would do so in a heartbeat. In the same program, Maria Chinquay rejected the apology, calling Anu the devil and responding, don't tell me this bullshit. You have killed
2017年，阿努出现在澳大利亚电视时事节目《星期日晚》上，并向钦奎一家公开道歉，她表示：“有很多事情是人们不理解的。有很多事情被忽视了。当时我患有非常、非常严重的精神疾病。如果我当时能听取别人的意见并寻求正确的心理帮助，这一切都不会发生。我想对玛丽亚和尼诺说，对于发生的事情，我感到无比、无比的抱歉，如果可以的话，如果有任何办法能让时光倒流，我会毫不犹豫地去做。”在同一节目中，玛丽亚·钦奎拒绝了道歉，称阿努为恶魔并回应道：“少跟我说这些废话。你杀了我生命中最宝贵的东西，我的大儿子，我的长子，那个本要继承他祖父名字的人，已经不在了。”
the most precious thing I had in my life, my first son, my firstborn, the one that was going to carry his grandfather's name is not here anymore. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。